[Musique]
si un mot qui résume bien le salon de
l'auto 2009 ses paradoxes tout le monde
tant de la voiture électrique il ya
encore cette année plus qu'elle n'a
jamais eu plus d'une quarantaine ya même
un parcours électrique cette année au
salon de l'auto mais paradoxalement on
assiste une fine hop et une épidémie de
véhicules utilitaires sport les
lancements cette année c'est presque
uniquement des benglis tour du salon
il ya beaucoup de 20 us c'est vrai mais
heureusement il y en option entièrement
électrique
c'est le cas du spectaculaire jaguar
eyed peas et c'est le cas également là
on tombe dans le domaine du plus
abordable du lion des connards qui est à
faire cette année en version 100%
électrique et l' argument vraiment
convaincants en faveur du kaunas et son
autonomie qui dépasse 400 km à ce salon
de l'auto 2010 neuf il ya même des
modèles de melgven juste juste à côté de
moi la kia soul qui est important c'est
que la version électrique et non
seulement reconduite mais les plus
puissantes c'est à dire la batterie en
plus d'autonomie que l'ancien plus du
double on passe de 179 kilomètres à 385
km une autre voiture électrique qui voit
son autonomie augmentée cette année
c'est la populaire ni 100 livres l'année
dernière elle a été entièrement
redessiné et cette année déjà une
amélioration on augmente l'autonomie de
la batterie donc une version plus
puissante dont l'autonomie peut dépasser
360 kg mal
[Musique]
quand on vient dans les salons de l'auto
on veut aussi voir l'avenir
on veut voir les prototypes les
véhicules concepts on en a 1 derrière
assez spectaculaire d'ailleurs du côté
de mitsubishi c'est rafraîchissant de
voir ça chez mitsubishi également un
constructeur ou on a un peu stanier ces
dernières années où on a d'ailleurs
abandonné aussi la production
d'automobiles traditionnels et en se
concentrant uniquement sur les
multisegments et les véhicules
utilitaires sport je vais us to b us
élevé usc le nouveau verbe à la mode
dans l'industrie automobile cette année
vraiment on n'y échappe pas on doit par
exemple rajoute un autre vie aux us dans
sa gamme le passeport qui lui vient
s'insérer entre le très populaire servi
et le pilote
même chose chez linkedin ou l'aviateur
lui vient s'insérer entre le nautilus et
le navigateur qui aurait dit un jour que
ray davies lamborghini des virus rose
rose à tous les constructeurs de
prestige y sont présents maintenant dans
ce créneau là ou presque les prix 250
milles jusqu'à 400 mille dollars
[Musique]
il n'y a pas seulement des v ux au salon
de tous il ya aussi des perdants y en a
encore qui se vendent très bien il faut
dire du coach finissant on vient de
renouveler l'altima qui se fait en
traction intégrale pour la première fois
et du côté de mazda exactement la même
chose avec la très populaire mazda 3 qui
pour la première fois elle aussi va être
offerte en version traction intégrale
quand on renouvelle un modèle populaire
on reste souvent dans la continuité
l'approchent prudente évolution plutôt
que révolution c'est le cas de la
nouvelle corolla c'est le cas également
du nouveau ford explorer par contre un
point commun entre ces deux modèles pour
la première fois ils sont offerts en
version hybride
ce qu'on aperçoit ici c'est une voiture
québécoise la féline au cb 7 pour sûr
qu'on a pu voir orient cinq ans ici au
salon de l'auto et cette année on
propose la cb cette aire qui est une
version routière donc être homologuée
pour la route
après une absence de plus de 25 ans
c'est le grand retour de la toyota supra
sportive mythique qui a été rendu
célèbre entre autres par la série de
films fast and furious grand retour de
cette voiture ça génère un bon et même
sans lui féminisme d'affirmer sa n'y a
pas beaucoup de voitures qui ont fait
autant parler d'elle au cours de la
dernière année voiture qui était attendu
de pied ferme et qui suscite des
relations très polarisée on aime ou on
n'aime pas du tout bonne route
[Musique]